nos dicen que 52 x 762 es igual a 39 mil
624 luego nos dicen relaciona cada
expresión con su producto y esto es de
un ejercicio de khan academy donde
podemos mover los productos para que se
relacionen con la expresión correcta
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
puede que se hayan dado cuenta de que
todas estas expresiones tienen los
mismos dígitos que 52 x 762 simplemente
tienen el punto decimal en posiciones
diferentes lo que podemos hacer es
darnos cuenta de que el resultado va a
tener los dígitos 3 962 y 4 en ese orden
lo que podemos ver en las opciones todas
tienen los dígitos 3 9 6 2 y 4 en ese
orden por lo que para estimar cuál será
el resultado de cada una de estas
expresiones tenemos que fijarnos en el
punto decimal para esta primera
expresión 0.52 x 76.2 la forma en que yo
pienso en ello es que es
52 es más cercano a un medio y 76.2 es
más cercano a 76 por lo que el producto
de esta primera expresión debe ser
aproximadamente la mitad de 76 y la
mitad de 76 es 38 y cuál de estas
opciones se acerca a 38 pues esta
primera 39.624 se acerca bastante a 38
de hecho es la más cercana a 38 el
siguiente es 396 y el otro es 3 1962 por
lo que me gusta esta opción me parece
correcta la siguiente expresión es 0.52
por 762 nuevamente 0.52 es cercano a 50
centésimas o cercano a 5 décimas o
también cercano a un medio y 762 podemos
decir que es algo más o menos aproximado
a 800 por lo que esto es más o menos la
mitad de 800 es decir alrededor
de 400 y de hecho ya tenemos esta opción
aquí 396 punto 24 definitivamente es la
opción correcta y 93 1960 y 2.4 y aquí
sólo nos queda tres mil 962 punto cuatro
por lo que estoy bastante segura de que
esta última opción debe estar aquí pero
vamos a verificarlo 5.2 es
aproximadamente 5 por 762 que digamos es
aproximadamente 800 5 por 800 es 4000
por lo que esperamos que el resultado de
esta expresión sea cercano a 4000 y
efectivamente coincide con esta opción
resulta que las opciones ya estaban en
el orden correcto pero es bueno que lo
hayamos verificado